[Musique]
bonsoir le début d'une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 60,18
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez nous
sommes le lundi 19 avril voici les
titres de ce journal 13000 personnes
vaccinées rien que la semaine dernière
la campagne bat son plein au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
transformer en vaccinodromes depuis la
mi janvier le président du sénat gérard
larcher s'est rendu sur place pour faire
le point avec les élus locaux et nous
vous en parlions la semaine dernière
cinq grands groupes ont lancé la
software et publics pour développer
ensemble la mobilité du futur cet
écosystème d'un s'installer et dont le
bâtiment odyssée du technocentre renault
de guyancourt et il reposera sur l'open
innovation explications et alors que la
deuxième semaine des vacances de pâques
comment ce retour sur cette animation du
week end à trappes l'adil organisé une
chasse aux oeufs géante pour les enfants
c'était samedi au parc du village
mais avant de développer ses titres
cette annonce du président de la
république dans le cadre de son
déplacement ce lundi à montpellier
emmanuel macron annoncé le déploiement
de dix mille policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires sur la durée et du
quinquennat pour les yvelines après
arbitrage avec le ministère de
l'intérieur
on apprend qu'il s'agira de 128 postes
de policiers crée rien que sur l'année
et 2021 est dans le détail 11 pour la
circonscription de sécurité publique de
versailles 18 pour celle de conflans 23
pourcel d'elancourt 21 pour celle de
menthe 39 pour celle de saint germain en
laye assez à 128 postes il faut ajouter
également lé 16 qui ont été déjà
annoncées du côté de sartrouville lors
du déplacement de gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur au début du mois
d'avril
comme chaque chaque début de semaine les
chiffres du colis 19 dans les yvelines
deux tendances avec d'un côté les
données de contamination sont qui sont
sur un plateau et qui restent hautes
elles le taux d'incidence nombre de
contaminés pour 100000 habitants a
reculé moins 32 en une semaine légère
hausse en revanche pour le taux de
positivité aux tests à l'hôpital et
chiffre continue d'augmenter 671
patients étaient hospitalisés hier sur
le sol libinois soit 41 de plus qu'il ya
une semaine 125 personnes était en
réanimation est depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
614 personnes sont décédées ducobu de 19
dans les hôpitaux du département est la
réponse à l'épidémie c'est bien sûr la
vaccination même si la menace du variant
brésilien se fait est de plus en plus
présentes parmi les sept centres de
vaccination dans les yvelines le
vaccinodromes de saint quentin en
yvelines qui tourne à plein régime en ce
mois d'avril est déjà quarante cinq
mille personnes qui ont reçu une
injection
vendredi dernier le président du sénat
gérard larcher est venu faire le point
avec les élus locaux le reportage de
bixente moyens santisteva la vaccination
bat son plein au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus de 2000
vaccins ils sont administrés chaque jour
en moyenne
vendredi 16 avril le président du sénat
gérard larcher est venu témoigner de
cette forte activité aux côtés des élus
locaux
c'est comme une start-up corps a été
créé en quelques mois et je veux dire
c'est une réussite pour l'instant il ya
un moral des troupes très fort les gens
qui ont qui sont dans l'équipe ont un
sentiment d'appartenance très fort de
voir leur de sauver des gens qu'en trois
mois le vaccinodromes a injecté plus de
45000 vaccin kaiser au modern art il
faut maintenant que nous les
parlementaires qui contrôlons l'état qui
votons les lois nous ressentions bien
les attentes attentes en termes bien sûr
de doses vaccinales et puis ici la
volonté un peu particulière d'assurer
une étude épidémiologique
cette étude vise à surveiller l'immunité
des vaccinés la protection des vaccins
varie entre 6 mois et un an selon les
personnes
objectif mieux appréhender les délais
d'immunité ce projet sur cent mille
personnes dans un territoire n'y a pas
beaucoup d'endroits
nous connaissons d'autres propositions
mais celle ci elle est particulièrement
importante par l'étendue de cette étude
le vélodrome rentrera bientôt dans une
nouvelle phase les quelques 400
personnels déployés pour assurer ce
rythme on risque encore d'augmenter
après le premier mais en tout cas on va
rentrer dans une
meilleures livraisons de vaccins et là
on va pouvoir effectivement monté si
bien entendu le ministre de la santé une
demande un rythme en augmentation
constante qui pourrait aller jusqu'à dix
mille injections par jour dans
l'actualité également la direction
interrégionale des douanes
d'ile-de-france qui dévoile ses derniers
chiffres
en 2020 le nombre de saisies de
contrefaçons a augmenté considérablement
près de 460 1500 articles soit une
hausse de 18 8% parmi les articles les
plus saisi l'an passé dans la région
c'était à prévoir avec la crise
sanitaire les masques chirurgicaux
arrive en première position avec plus de
220 milles saisies suivies des écouteurs
bluetooth et des chargeurs de téléphones
portables 68 1551 saisit enfin les
chaussures avec environ 40 de 1900 père
au total ces saisies représentent plus
de 4,2 millions d'euros au prix de
l'authentiqué un manque à gagner de
plusieurs millions d'euros pour
l'économie souterraine
la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires jacqueline gourault s'est
rendu à sartrouville en fin de semaine
dernière au programme de sa visite
l inauguration de la maison france
service elle a été ouverte en mai 2020
pour aider aux démarches administratives
et elle vient d'être labellisé par
l'état et les explications dans ce sujet
de justin brasier la voie des stries
bergère elles sont cinq dans les
yvelines la maison france services de
sartrouville et la 1300e du pays
son but accompagner les citoyens dans
leurs démarches administratives pour
pallier les difficultés d'accès au droit
les citoyens peuvent avoir des réponses
à des questions de la vie quotidienne
d'accompagnement pour refaire une carte
d'identité pour demander des apl pour et
posé une question de droit l'équipe de
sartrouville accueille 250 personnes par
mois
elles viennent vérifier leurs démarches
ou encore connaître leurs droits
objectif de l'établissement concentré en
un seul lieu plusieurs services publics
ici il existe une dizaine d'institutions
c'est un lieu où les personnes peuvent
venir et résoudre leur problématique que
ce soit aussi bien pour l'emploi
de la caf que la cnav donc la retraite
donc c'est vraiment on va dire une
institution qui on regroupe des
institutions publiques les maisons
france services se situent dans des
zones très rurales ou semi rurale ou
encore dans des quartiers politiques
prioritaires de la ville comme c'est le
cas ici à sartrouville
le besoin est encore plus accrue parce
que les citoyens les administrés sont
très éloignés des services publics et
donc ils ont besoin qu'on vienne vers
qu'on les aide
on les accompagne on sait qu'il ya des
vrais problèmes d'accès au droit
aujourd'hui d'accès aux droits sociaux
d'accès à la justice
une campagne de communication a été
lancée pour faire connaître ses services
de proximité
objectif comptait 2000 maisons
françaises dans le pays d'ici la fin de
l'année
michel le bot confirmé dans ses
fonctions de maire de magnanville le
conseil d'état vient de valider la
dernière élection municipale dans la
ville scrutin que le tribunal
administratif de versailles avait
pourtant annulé en septembre
au coeur de cette première décision la
diffusion d'une vidéo qui aurait
compromis la sincérité d'élections
remportées par michelle lebouc avec 35
voix d'avancé sur la liste de nicolas
laroche finalement ce jugement a été
infirmé par le conseil d'état qui écarte
également les autres éléments du recours
déposé par le conseiller municipal et
dylan guelton renault atos dassault
systèmes stmicroelectronics et thales
ont officialisé le 9 avril dernier le
lancement de la software république
c'est un programme qui vise à développer
les futurs services et solutions autour
de la mobilité de demain une mobilité
qui se veut écologique est connecté pour
en parler nicolas landry des rédactions
tv 78,11 soir bonsoir grégory cette
initiative s'inscrit dans une démarche
d'open innovation alors on entend
souvent parler de ce terme notamment
dans vos émissions nicolas landry du du
sky échos mais concrètement qu'est ce
que l'open innovation l'open une raison
c'est l'innovation ouverte jusqu'à
maintenant je vous apprends rien grégory
c'est la traduction en français
pour être plus clair c'est une stratégie
pour une entreprise dans laquelle elle
va engager et ouvrir ses moyens pour
innover au coeur de cette pratique il y
à l'intelligence humaine et les échanges
de connaissances
prenons un exemple à une société entre
dans une démarche d'open innovation
quand elle crée des collaborations avec
ses clients ses fournisseurs d'autres
entreprises ça peut être aussi des
laboratoires de recherche des start up
ou des collectivités locales
objectif c'est de concevoir des
innovations en partageant les expertises
de chacun et quels sont les différents
modèles doper l'innovation en général on
retrouve les démarches degré
d'innovation dans les grands groupes
par exemple en accueillant des
entrepreneurs qui vont présenter leurs
technologies aux salariés du groupe
si un intérêt commun n'est
l'entrepreneur peut être accueillis dans
les locaux pour développer son activité
elle va être soutenue par le groupe en
fait il existe aussi des concours
d'innovation des starters peuvent être
sélectionnés mais il peut aussi y avoir
de l'open innovation en interne entre
les salariés d'une même entreprise
est-ce que vous avez des exemples d'open
innovation à nous deux à nous donner
pour ce soit plus concret il ya beaucoup
d'exemples de paix innovations sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
par exemple à airbus défense n space à
elancourt avec un espace dédié à cela
pour accueillir des dirigeants de start
up qui vient de présenter les
technologies vous avez le projet vous en
avez beaucoup parlé dans le journal le
projet autour de persévérance
le rover actuellement présents sur mars
c'est aussi une démarche l'open
innovation de grande ampleur au niveau
international avec des entreprises des
laboratoires de recherche et des
infrastructures gouvernementales comme
la nasa enfin vous avez parlé de la
software et public avec les cinq grands
groupes mentionnés qui souhaite
rassembler des entreprises des start up
des universités et des collectivités
locales autour d'elle pour développer
des innovations dans le secteur de la
mobilité
merci nicolas pour toutes ces précisions
maintenant que nous a donné toutes les
clés pour comprendre ce sujet je vous
propose de regarder cette interio
nikolov vous êtes vous avez rencontré le
responsable de la software république
pour le groupe renoue regarder la soirée
publique c'est l'histoire d'une
collaboration entre cinq grands
industriels français le groupe renault
atos dassault systèmes
stmicroelectronics et thales et pour
parler de ce sujet nous sommes avec
françois dosse à bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le responsable de la sauve toi
république pour le groupe renault
quel est l'objectif de ce programme
industriel alors vous savez puisque on
en a déjà pas mal parler l'idée c'est de
créer un écosystème qui va travailler
sur les logiciels
pourquoi travailler sur les logiciels
parce que les logiciels finalement c'est
la valeur future du véhicule de demain
et de la mobilité de demain
donc il va y avoir énormément d'avancées
dans ses logiciels
alors on aurait pu le faire tout seul on
a préféré s'associer à des champions
comme tous ceux que vous avez cités
plus nous pour le faire ensemble parce
qu'on pense qu'on sera beaucoup plus
efficace et beaucoup plus fort si on le
fait ensemble
le qg de la sauve toi république sera
dans le bâtiment odyssée le nouveau
bâtiment du technocentre renault de
guyancourt
ce sera sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines déjà pourquoi ce
choix
exactement alors on sera on sera ici
parce que on est observée au début du
plateau de saclay et le plateau de
saclay c'est un plateau d'intelligence
des expertises de grands entreprises de
centres de recherche des meilleures
universités françaises et donc on aura
cette proximité
on a aussi sur le plateau de saclay
beaucoup de startups qui sont déjà
actives dans les domaines qui nous
intéresse l'intelligence artificielle la
cyber sécurité et donc on pense qu'on va
pouvoir catalyser autour de nous autour
de ce bâtiment que vous avez mentionné
qui est un bâtiment tout neuf magnifique
tout en bois et verre très collaboratif
et voilà donc on sera c'est pour ça
qu'on a voulu cet endroit sur le plateau
de saclay nous c'est comme ça qu'on le
conte l'expriment cinq industriels
fondateur vous parlez des start-up ya
aussi les centres de recherche qui peut
être concerné pourquoi parce que nous
sommes dans une démarche d'open
innovation c'est comme ça que vous
l'imaginez l'open innovation pour
développer la mobilité de demain
absolument en fait louvain d'écosystèmes
c'est un écosystème est un écosystème
ouvert large donc effectivement vous
avez bien vu il ya les cinq groupes que
vous avez nommés mais on sera pas que
les simples qui en aura d'autres qui
vont venir des grandes entreprises des
entreprises moyennes des petites
entreprises
bien sûr des start up ça c'est très
important les centres de recherche de
façon à ce qu'on ait toute la chaîne
bout en bout des logiciels vous savez
que c'est un monde qui est très évolutif
où les choses ont très très vite et donc
pour nous notamment avoir ces startups
qu'une capacité de créer en permanence
des choses très disruptive très
novatrice pour nous c'est très important
vous avez cité un chacun leur domaine
d'activité il ya l'intelligence
artificielle ia la big data il ya les
composants électroniques
il ya la mobilité l'automobile avec le
groupe renault et puis il ya la
cybersécurité comme en agglomère toutes
ces activités pour proposer justement d
offre des solutions pour la mobilité de
demain
alors on le fait
très bonne question parce
qu'effectivement il faut que chacun
apporte sa contribution à d'abord un
premier temps s'est bien rendu compte
qu'il n'y avait pas d'eau vers la ventre
les uns et les autres chacun
effectivement apporte sa brique et
comment on le fait en fait on le fait en
partant de cas d'application très
concret et on dit voilà sur ce cas là
est ce qu'on est tous d'accord qui a un
intérêt
oui alors qu'est ce que chacun peut
apporter moi je peux apporter cette
brique technologique moi j'apporte samoa
et ont bâti comme ça ensemble une offre
où on arrive à faire finalement une
offre complète qu'aucun de nous tous
seuls n'arriverait à faire c'est ça qui
est finalement la force de cette de cet
écosystème et où vous l'aurez compris en
fait c'est pas qu'on additionne c'est
plutôt qu'on multiplie donc un effet
vraiment des multiplicateurs qui est
très fort quand vous parlez d usage
ça peut être quoi par exemple pour
illustrer leur on a annoncé déjà un
certain nombre de deux projets un projet
qui est le projet de plug in charge où
on pourra charger sur des bornes
n'importe quelle voiture électrique
alors qu'aujourd'hui vous avez que
chacun a sa à son système les systèmes
ne sont pas compatibles et c'est donc
une facilité beaucoup plus grande pour
les utilisateurs et donc ça c'est faire
que des software afin dé logiciels se
parlez-en aux autres etc
pour faciliter la vie des consommateurs
et l'autre qui alors là vous allez le
comprendre encore plus important je
dirais c'est s'adresse aux collectivités
les aider à faire des simulations de
flux parce que vous savez qu'on vit
encore dans beaucoup d'embouteillages
beaucoup d'accidents beaucoup de vies
sont encore malheureusement perdu de
tous les ans est donc là la software
république va proposer aux collectivités
aux villes qu'elles soient grandes ou
petites
des solutions pour gérer leurs flux
d'une façon très différente et qui va
faciliter là aussi la vie des citoyens
des consommateurs
deux dernières questions comment chacun
va y trouver son compte à leur foi entre
les cinq industriels mais aussi les
startups à ce qu'on sait parfois que les
entrepreneurs peuvent être frileux a
collaboré avec des grands groupes de
peur d'être absorbé de perdre un peu
l'essence même de leur société alors les
start up est très claire on ne va pas
proposer de les racheter
ce que vous avez raison si on rachète
une start-up la chance que
elle se retrouve pas dans des grands
groupes et très très grande donc l'idée
est plutôt de les aider en investissant
dans ces start-up mais de façon
minoritaire de façon à respecter leur
identité leur façon de travailler mais
en leur donnant quand même la chance de
pouvoir travailler avec nous et
notamment d'avoir accès à des volumes
beaucoup plus important et donc ça on
pense que c'est un peu le win win le
gagnant gagnant tant pour la start-up
que pour nous donc plutôt investissement
minoritaire et après travail en commun
pour ensemble aussi constituer cet
écosystème est la dernière question en
lien un peu avec ce que vous dites un
investissement mettre à disposition
peut-être des locaux comment ça va se
mettre en place
concrètement à partir du mois de
septembre parce que le bâtiment 10 et
sera inauguré au mois de septembre
comment ça va se mettre en place
quelle forme ça va prendre avec
peut-être des incubateurs je sais pas
ce bâtiment ce sera un espèce de l'awb
très intéressant dans lequel on sera
tous les membres fondateurs que dont on
a parlé déjà depuis le début mais
également d'autres les start up par
exemple alors je vous donne un exemple
offert des lacaton les start up qui vont
gagner
c'est à caton on va les loger on va leur
dire voilà pendant un an vous êtes
gratuitement ici avec nous pour
travailler avec nous plus profondément
on voudrait effectivement avoir un
incubateur de start up et un
accélérateur donc prendre des start up
qui match avec ce qu'on veut faire pour
les incubés ensuite les accélérer les
passer à l'échelle et si elle gagne on
gagne à nouveau toujours dans cette dans
cette relation gagnant gagnant
l'idée de ce qu'on veut faire c'est
vraiment créer un espèce de lab ou comme
le dit moi mon patron
en fait c'est à la machine à café qu'on
en discute et qu'on va échanger et qu'on
va se comprendre et qu'on va créer et
donc c'est ça le bâtiment odyssée c'est
un peu toute cette idée de ce
laboratoire un peu nouveau qui travers à
cet écosystème
merci françois doz ça c'est moi qui vont
lancer responsable de la sauve toi
république pour le groupe renault
la direction saint germain en laye à
présent pour vous parler d'une invention
d'un ingénieur yvelinois une table basse
qui se transforme en un bureau mais
surtout en une station informatiques
pratiques pour le télétravail
présentation avec eléonore si nokia une
table basse qui se transforme en
trente secondes enduro c'est l'invention
de marseille ingénieurs polyvalents et
habitant de saint germain en laye et
cette table n'est pas seulement un
nabeul la table se déplie totalement et
se transforme en station informatique
totalement complète où il ya plus qu'à
pleurer son ordinateur la table et
travail idéales pour le télétravail
notamment avec le développement de cette
pratique pendant la crise sanitaire
la table n'avait pourtant pas cet
objectif à la base ce qui est marrant
c'est que ça n'a rien à voir avec le co
vide où la crise sanitaire g c'était en
2011 2012 un été où j'avais envie de
jouer aux jeux vidéo depuis mon canapé
il n'y a pas de solution pour jouer
depuis son canapé
donc je me suis amusé cet été-là à
bricoler un premier prototype de table
qui se range facilement le soir un puis
deux puis trois prototypes plus tard
omar s'est créé la job staple la table
s'adapte donc à la taille de la personne
utilisable sur un canapé ou avec une
chaise de bureau classique
elle est aussi à la pointe de la
technologie enceinte rangement pour
disque dur ou encore écran 27 pouces
mais pas que la table un texte de base
une vitre heures c'est assez spécifique
n'existe pas ailleurs une vie tactile
hier que le plateau vitry de la table
intègre déjà un clavier tactile et un
trackpad tactile qui fait quand on dans
l'utilisation la plus simple de la
taille vous avez même pas sortir un
clavier et une souris c'est même déjà ça
aussi intégré dans la table aujourd'hui
son objectif est bien sûr de trouver des
clients pour vendre sa table un produit
autour des 3000 euros omar seck devrait
aussi participer au concours lépine
prochainement l'édition 2020 avait été
annulée mais sa table est toujours en
lice pour 2021
si la crise sanitaire le permet c'était
ce week-end les obsèques du prince
philip se sont déroulés samedi dernier
au château de windsor le duc d'edimbourg
est décédé pour rappel le 9 avril
dernier à 99 ans et ses clichés des
archives nationales nous rappelle que
l'époux de la reine elizabeth ii était
venu chasser à rambouillet c'était le 18
octobre 1952 à l'invitation du président
de la république vincent auriol
on y voit le prince philippe fusil en
main ou comme sur ce cliché le lendemain
lors d'une visite à la bergerie
nationale à la découverte des moutons de
mérinos attrape la ville a organisé une
chasse aux oeufs ce week-end les enfants
avaient rendez vous au parc le village
au programme ramassage des oeufs et
aussi des questions de culture générale
chacun est reparti ensuite avec ses
chocolats et justine brazy a pu suivre
les recherches la voix sur ce reportage
de mélanie poker c'est une chasse aux
oeufs géante qui a pris possession du
parc municipal le village samedi 17
avril à trappes
de quoi occuper les enfants en cette
période de vacances scolaires ont permis
aux enfants de profiter de ce joli parc
immense que peu de trapèze connaissent
d'ailleurs qu'ils puissent en profiter
en plein air en respectant les gestes
barrières les distances de sécurité
parce qu'on est en période kovy d'un
qu'il faut évidemment être très attentif
à ces aspects et les services municipaux
se sont mobilisés dans différents
services jeunesse sports centre
socioculturel elle les enfants devaient
ramasser dans le pâté eu deux couleurs
objectif reconstituer un panier de 6 des
petites batteries sont de la même
couleur
d'abord il faudra les mettre dans la
boîte dessus en fait on a mis une petite
étiquette de couleurs qui correspond en
fait aux six couleurs qui doivent
récupérer
donc en fait j'ai ensuite ils font le
parcours dans le parc municipal qui est
séparé en six zones de couleurs pouvoir
amasser 1 9 de couleur vous le mettez
dans la boîte il faut que vous allez
remplir la boîte avec les six couleurs
différentes pour les plus grands des
questions de culture générale ont été
disposés sur le parcours avec à la clé
un tirage au sort
d'accord j'ai des chaînes ont dit qu'ils
ne rateront une éruption dit que je
devais l'être questionnaire les bois une
fois sa mission accomplie chaque enfant
et chant sa voix de femme placée contre
un sachet de chocolats des chocolats oui
parce que tu as bien travaillé
j'ai dû trouver les plus de 1000 enfants
ont profité de la chasse aux oeufs de
trappes ce week end à nous refermons ce
journal à orgeval où l'équipe de casting
de qu'est-ce qu'on a tous fait au bon
dieu recherche des figurants
il s'agit du troisième volet du film
qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon dieu avec
chantal lauby et christian clavier
réalisé par philippe de chauveron
le tournage aura lieu à partir du 17 mai
prochain pour une durée d'une à trois
journées les figurants recherché elles
doivent avoir entre 8 et 80 ans être
véhiculée à habiter le secteur des
profils avec une expérience
professionnelle dans la restauration
sont également recherchées chaque
journée sera rémunéré à 105 euros bruts
pour postuler rendez vous sur le site
qui s'affiche www.cat prod.com sortie du
film prévue pour le 13 octobre 2021
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité et dans un instant
vous retrouverez le 7-8 sport présentée
par michael almy d'euros belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]